une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on
parle ce qu'on veut que nos invités
pour recevoir son chef et ils ont
répondu à la pharmacie donc on a parlé
aujourd'hui avec Paul sapiens-plamondon
on a parlé beaucoup d'indépendance de
pourquoi on voudrait faire
l'indépendance pourquoi c'est encore
pourquoi ça serait encore pertinent
aujourd'hui c'est quoi les avantages
c'est quoi les désavantages du
nationalisme selon lui c'est vraiment
c'est pas pertinent à parler de
plusieurs enjeux d'actualité comme le
chemin Roxanne par exemple qui était
beaucoup dans les médias dernièrement on
a peu parlé du serment à la reine mais
on aurait pu en parler mais finalement
vous irez lire ce qui s'est passé puis
super super intéressant je pense que
c'est des conversations comme ça qui me
moi je suis un souverainiste non
militant d'enfance dans ce que je vois
très oui et quand on sort d'une
conversation comme ça tout le temps un
petit peu plus engagé dans cette
cause-là dans construire un Québec dans
où est-ce qu'on s'en va en tant que
nation en tant que peuple en tant que
culture je pense que c'est super
pertinent de parler de réfléchir à ça
moi aussi je suis
je me séparatiste non engagé mais j'ai
l'impression que s'il y avait
servi le déclenchement de référendum je
pense que je prendrais plus paroles j'ai
l'impression que je serai plus actif je
serais un activiste pour le oui sûrement
j'ai l'impression que je suis peut-être
j'utiliserais ma plateforme ou que
moi-même j'essaierai de convaincre mes
proches mes amis parce que c'est quelque
chose qui me tient quand même à cœur
puis vous allez voir dans le podcast
on se l'explique assez bien en fait
pourquoi ce serait important
de faire du Québec nation un pays puis
pourquoi que notre culture est unique
qui est belle qui piquait mérite d'être
peut être protégé puis comment aussi
réconcilier en fait cette protection là
dans un monde de plus en plus
multiculturelle de plus en plus
justement d'ouverture vers l'autre
comment qu'on réconcilie en fait
protéger notre langue notre culture et
aussi l'ouverture vers l'autre puis
l'acceptation des doutes différentes
donc je pense que ça vision est
intéressante tout à fait pour le moins
donc bon podcast bonne écoute le podcast
de cette semaine est présenté par nos
amis chez manscape qui viennent de
sortir le kit
ultime pour la barbe ici c'est le build
Edge qui est un trimeur pour la barbe
puis la chose ultime dans ce produit là
c'est que vous pouvez décider il y a
quand même une petite roulette autour
qui décide la longueur que vous voulez
avoir de votre barbe ça va de 0.5
jusqu'à 10 puis moi c'est un problème
que j'avais parce que on en parlait
souvent je me faisais la barre avec le
voyant le
lendemain 4.0 mais lendemain avait deux
longueurs seulement ceux-là il y a
toutes les longueurs que vous voulez
dans le fond c'est clair à partir
maintenant je vais pouvoir avoir la
barbe idéale tout le temps t'as pas un
million de petites pièces qu'elle est
non
ce n'est que la longueur idéale puis en
plus de ça en plus de dans le package du
beat ager ça vient avec plein d'autres
affaires par mois
de barbe là dedans tu as vraiment tout
ce que tu as besoin pour avoir la barbe
ultime la barbe
toujours de mal one beer roulement puis
dans le fond mais on a même une petite
marche à suivre qui est détaillée ici on
a tous ce qu'on a besoin pour laver la
barbe on a un shampoing à barbe après ça
on va se peigner avec ce petit peigne là
après ça on va se
s'étendre cette Crimée la barbe à la
longueur idéale avec ceux on se fait une
petite finition au ciseau après ça on la
brosse et on se met pommade une petite
tuile qu'elle soit bien
bien
lisse et bien placé mais parfaite donc
avec une barbe comme ça ça va changer
votre vie c'est sûr si vous ou quelqu'un
dans votre vie a une barbe c'est un Game
changer honnêtement là nous on a reçu
les trucs le je ramène ça chez nous
définitivement puis ça va être ma
nouvelle routine de barbe puis on a un
code promo pour vous autres qui est le
même code qu'on utilise tout le temps
c'est le sans filtre pour 20% de rabais
et la livraison gratuite sûr tous les
produits manscape mais principalement le
nouveau build ager donc sauter là-dessus
puis oubliez pas du vider le code promo
comme ça ils vont savoir que c'est nous
qui vous envoie c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est bon pour vous qui avez une
barbe c'est bon pour la personne que
vous connaissez Gavin barbe c'est bon
pour nous c'est bon pour mannequin c'est
bon pour Nicole qui nous écoute en ce
moment c'est bon pour tout le monde
Skype promo sans fil 20% de rabais
livraison gratuite sur télé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là premièrement bonjour
bonjour
je vais j'avais même pas planifié de
parler de ça pitié l'actualité est
tellement effervescente en ce moment
qu'on a plein de choses à parler puis
j'avais pas planifié ça mais ça m'est
arrivé hier en fait je veux qu'on en
discute puis je veux qu'on aille tu vois
parce que moi j'habite à Québec
maintenant cette semaine ma voiture
j'habite dans le Saint-Jean-Baptiste un
vieux quartier il y a un bloc de glace
qui est tombé sur mon char ça a détruit
le toit ça détruit la fenêtre arrière
bref mon chat est au garage puis là je
dois venir à Montréal ça fait un petit
bout que je pense déjà laisser ma
voiture de côté fait que je me dis je
vais prendre le transport en commun
c'est le transport du futur tu sais que
je prends un billet aller-retour en
train quand je fais Québec Montréal avec
mon char de chez nous à schéma blonde
deux heures 45 pour ta porte exemple
hier ça m'a pris 6 heures porte à porte
quand je fais Québec Montréal monchard
ça me coûte 60 pièces d'essence max il y
a son côté 180 pièces pour le billet
aller-retour en train quand je fais
Québec Montréal avec mon chat j'ai une
hybride je suis pas très polluant hier
je suis dans un train qui est à peu près
1000 places on était peut-être 40
maximum et que j'imagine qu'au niveau de
la pollution c'est pas optimal non plus
puis là j'étais dans le train et puis je
réfléchis je me disais on est tellement
loin de quelque chose de pratique
pour convaincre les gens d'arrêter de
prendre leur voiture qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec ça parce que hier je réfléchis
à ça je me dis tiens je vais en profiter
pour poser la question parce que
commencer
je trouve qu'on est tellement loin
la campagne tu avais
QS qui ont sorti un plan énorme que je
me disais c'est bien trop gros mais en
même temps je me dis on est tellement
loin de quelque chose qui est pratique
que ça prend quelque chose de radical
comme ça ça a pas de bon sens
radical premièrement le plan du PQ celui
de QS le selon les experts était pas mal
équivalent d'avoir la volonté de taxer
la planification qu'on faisait de ces
questions là ça ressemblait je dirais
pas que c'est radical c'est marqué c'est
massif
ça se fait en Europe ça se fait
mais là c'est là qu'on embarque dans la
discussion de fond c'est à dire est-ce
que notre démocratie fonctionne sur la
base de ce qui est important pour les
gens
si certains partis n'en parlent pas de
transport collectif non
vraisemblablement aucune intention de
s'en occuper puis parle de tunnel puis
que les gens choisissent ça mais le
moment donné aussi le faux faut juste
rappeler que l'exercice qui est déjà qui
est déjà mince là c'est à dire une fois
ou quatre ans aller voter on s'entend
que c'est pas un taux de participation à
nous décisions collectives qui est très
élevées si cette fois là
nos votes sont pas cohérents avec nos
préoccupations ben ça donne ça donne une
offre de transport collectif qui
décourage pour lui récemment à Montréal
il y avait une garantie de la STM de
offrir un service dix minutes ou moins
qui le vient comme ça d'être retiré donc
ça veut dire que les
attentes vont être plus élevées les
délais d'attente pardon donc ça ça veut
dire que c'est de moins en moins
attrayant de l'utiliser donc c'est une
roue qui tourne
du mauvais côté puis c'est toujours une
question de choix il y a un budget
limité et on doit se poser la question
qu'est-ce qui prioritaire dans quoi on
investit puisse pour ça que les cadres
budgétaires proposés par chaque partie
devrait être étudié dans un monde idéal
pour que les gens se posent la question
mais moi est-ce que qu'est-ce qui répond
à mes priorités qu'est-ce qui est bien
fait qui est pragmatique parce que c'est
une chose aussi de rêver
à mieux mais c'est aussi important de le
faire avec rigueur peut-être capable de
le faire atterrir donc toutes ces
questions là normalement c'est ceux qui
devrait nous préoccuper lors des
élections puis moi je constate que
d'élection en élection c'est question là
nous on est arrivé avec la passe climat
qui était vraiment quelque chose
d'innovateur mais qui se fait en Europe
à nouveau de dire on augmente de
beaucoup l'offre et on rend ça très très
attrayant sur le plan financier
mais bon c'est ça on va revenir à la
charge en espérant que les gens
répondent présent mais c'est toujours
entre les mains de la population
parce que moi
je me disais moi qui pensais faire la
bonne chose en me disant je veux laisser
tomber ma voiture quand mon bail va
terminer c'est juste pas impossible
actuellement mais tu sais que vis à rail
c'est pas le gouvernement du Québec ce
gouvernement fédéral donc là ça c'est un
autre parti de ce dossier là c'est que
pour plusieurs questions
le train devrait se rendre plus loin il
devrait fonctionner en Gaspésie
présentement il est construit
bizarrement ou est-ce que il y a du
commercial qui passe en même temps que
du transport de gestion
tout seul on n'a pas le pouvoir donc
souvent on parle de l'indépendance du
Québec que je représente en politique
comme d'un lubie quelque chose de
ludique quelque chose qui serait le fun
mais là il y a d'autres priorités en
fait quand on regarde chacune de nos
priorités ça arrive presque jamais que
la question qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir
puis que la moitié la presque la moitié
de nos impôts se rendent à Ottawa qui
est un gouvernement qui n'a pas
autant à coeur nos intérêts qui souvent
prend des décisions qui ne correspondent
pas à notre volonté ça arrive presque
jamais que cette question-là n'arrive
n'est pas soulevée
donc c'est pas théorique c'est souvent
très très concret dans chaque problème
de stansion par beaucoup de santé
selon toutes les provinces donc c'est
pas que le Québec exagère au Québec il
nous manque 5 milliards par année dans
le système de santé qui devrait nous
revenir de tawa
Ottawa avec ces sommes là fait plutôt
d'autres projets souvent des projets de
dédoublement de ce que le Québec fait
déjà donc il y a un ministère de la
Santé à Ottawa mais pourtant la santé
c'est nous qui la livrons à Québec
il y a presque pas de service direct à
la population qui est fait par le
gouvernement fédéral
à part les passeports
qui sont pas toujours facile
mais ça ne coûte presque la moitié de
nos impôts pourquoi à part du
dédoublement puis des conflits d'intérêt
ou est-ce que le fédéral doit choisir
entre ce que l'Alberta veut l'Ontario le
Québec le tout le monde se chamaille
donc moi je crois vraiment que pour
toutes sortes de raisons on pourrait en
parler aussi le mais des raisons de
protection de nos intérêts dans un futur
qui me semble instable potentiellement
instable je touche du bois puis je le
souhaite pas mais des pandémies des
guerres des crises mondiales
si c'est ça notre conclusion je pense je
suggère fortement qu'on prenne nos
décisions nous-mêmes en fonction de la
protection de nos intérêts mais laissez
d'autres gouvernements ou des gens qui
ont d'autres intérêts décider pour nous
comme là dans les journaux de stancy
c'est notre sous-sol minier qui contrôlé
par des entreprises étrangères mais
laissez-nous ressources puisque
l'essentiel pour notre alimentation
notre protection dans les mains
d'intérêt autre que les nôtres c'est un
risque qu'on devrait pas prendre avec ce
que je pense qu'on va vivre ne serait-ce
que l'adaptation changement climatique
puisque ça peut impliquer
cette semaine parce que parlons
d'indépendance je pense qu'on peut
sauter directement dans le sujet cette
semaine il y a eu une échange en toi et
le Premier ministre sur les transferts
en santé justement puis sur je pense que
tu lui demandais de reconnaître ou de
faire une commission sur
le fédéralisme au Québec je pense le
commission d'études sur l'impact du
fédéralisme sur le Québec notamment
commis ça nous coûte c'est ça puis
qu'est-ce que ça nous rapporte parce
qu'en ce moment on entend une guerre de
chiffres très politisés c'était le
François
Lego c'est ce que François Le Goodzi
parce que c'est un argument qui
j'imagine pour les gens qui
s'intéressent
sommairement à l'indépendance du Québec
ou que c'est pas une préoccupation ils
doivent se dire automatiquement on
reçoit plus que ce qu'on donne
fait que c'est quoi où est-ce qu'elle
est la vérité est mais justement c'est
pour ça qu'une commission nous donnerait
leur juste je pense pas que François
Legault dit la vérité lorsqu'il dit
qu'on envoie qu'on reçoit 10 milliards
de plus que ce qu'on envoie à ta voix on
envoie à ta voix au dessus de 60
milliards
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait examiner
qu'est-ce qu'on obtient pour ce 60
milliards là par rapport à ce que on
ferait de ce 60 milliards là s'il était
sur notre contrôle surtout puis c'est ça
la question que c'est complexe mais ça
devrait être étudié plus sérieusement
que des bouteilles puis
rappelons que François Legault en
campagne quand le PQ monté a fait une
sortie dans la dernière semaine de
campagne pour dire le Québec indépendant
serait viable sur le plan financier
je vous soumets respectueusement qu'on
peut paifier à la parole de François
Legault ça arrive très souvent qu'il dit
une chose et son contraire en fonction
de ce que ces conseillers qui ont le
sondage du jour devant sous les yeux
le je pense qu'il mise sur le fait que
on oublie puis que les gens sont très
occupés et que donc puis je blâme
personne les gens sont occupés quand tu
as des enfants en bas âge puis tu as une
job puis t'as de la misère à rejoindre
les deux bouts c'est pas vrai que tu lis
chaque article puis tu gardes un aide
mémoire de chaque déclaration du thème
mais moi c'est ma job je l'ai sous les
yeux tout le temps puis c'est ça la
réalité donc
nous là dedans je pense notre rôle c'est
de parler l'indépendance comme une
nécessité
et non pas comme un projet facultatif
puis à chaque fois que la CAQ tente de
décourager les Québécois quant à leur
capacité de décider par eux-mêmes mais
c'est de ramener la claque à la réalité
puis d'ustensiles Canada est juste un
Trudeau ramène la caque à la réalité
constamment c'est à dire que une demande
de tweet une lettre une demande
d'intervenir auprès des Américains une
demande il y a rien qui fonctionne
et on était une époque quand même où la
question climatique et vraiment mal
aligné la question linguistique est en
déclin puis au quotidien
je comptais le nombre les gens suivent
pas l'Assemblée nationale puis je les
plains pas pourtant
Assemblée nationale moi-même honnêtement
je trouve que l'exercice
je dois peser mon mot là parce qu'il
faut que je te mets ressenti mais
une valeur ajoutée limitée
[Rires]
mais au sens où c'est au lieu de
collaborer comme dans d'autres systèmes
on a un système de tradition britannique
ou tu as le droit de poser une question
au Premier ministre puis il y a le droit
de te répondre n'importe quoi donc à
quoi ça nous avance
on voit souvent c'est que les plats
passés juste une question
une réponse qui aurait rien à voir avec
la question re question exacte même
chose re questions même chose surtout de
toutes les parties
ça fonctionne mais je parlais de cet
exemple là excuse-moi je me suis perdu
dans le
dans le sujet on parlait pas des
questions on parlait de sur
l'indépendance ah c'est ça c'est que le
nombre de motions donc une motion c'est
clair c'est une résolution c'est de dire
moi je pense qu'on devrait tous affirmer
la même chose voulez-vous voter avec moi
donc c'est comme une façon pour
l'Assemblée nationale de parler d'une
seule voix
on est rendu depuis le début de janvier
on est juste en février on est rendu à
cette résolutions unanime qui blâme le
fédéral ou demande aux fédérales de
faire quelque chose
qui se passe rien à chaque fois c'est
comme on est unanimement fiable souvent
on s'applaudit
en tout cas j'ai envoyé toute une lettre
puis je viens de demander de tweeter
c'est pas sans rien il se passe rien
donc il y a comme un lien avec la
réalité qu'il faut reprendre
la folie c'est de répéter toujours les
mêmes erreurs toujours les mêmes choses
en se disant que la prochaine fois ça va
donner un résultat différent puis moi je
pense que n'importe quel observateur de
ce qu'on fait à l'Assemblée nationale
vous direz que il y a très peu de chance
que le Québec puisse être autonome dans
le Canada puisse prendre ses décisions
en fonction de sa situation particulière
ces intérêts c'est plus probable qu'on
se rend dans l'indépendance du Québec
qu'on puisse se rendre à l'autonomie
dans le Canada parce que là c'est testé
et sur tester ça fait cinq ans que ça
avance pas et on voit que notre poids
politique qui est en chute libre dans le
Canada notre poids démographique fait en
sorte que les gouvernements poliev qui
est probablement le remplaçant de Justin
Trudeau éventuellement regarde la carte
politique puisse j'ai pas besoin du
Québec pour me faire élire faut que je
convainque une partie de l'Ontario puis
j'ai l'Ouest canadienne Montbard mais le
Québec étant complètement à part dans
une réalité très particulière ne fait
pas partie du calcul politique mais dans
ce temps-là ça veut dire que tu fais pas
partie du calcul politique quand il y a
des arbitrages entre les provinces à qui
on envoie le contrat de construction de
bateau à qui est-ce qu'on donne l'usine
de pile de lithium à qui est-ce qu'on
donne un investissement direct pour
soutenir toutes ces questions là sont en
fonction de la réélection des
gouvernements et la réélection des
gouvernements il y a déjà eu une époque
où ça prenait Québec pour être premier
ministre du Canada c'est plus le cas ça
explique que ce que vous vous souvenez
de la chanson de campagne électorale du
Parti libéral du Canada
mais tu as pas un message plus clair ok
c'est un parti national il y a deux
langues officielles puis ta chanson est
inintelligible en français puis tu dis
c'est ça qu'on va envoyer dans l'espace
public c'est parce qu'en fait ça n'a
aucune importance pour ton élection
est-ce que
la présence du bloc autant
potentiellement nécessaire pour défendre
les intérêts du Québec à pas un peu
Chris
admettons que le blog n'existait pas
puis que les parties qui vont gouverner
Ottawa aurait besoin ou les sièges
québécois aurait plus de d'impact que
qui en ont maintenant parce que là c'est
quoi ces 30 cake
députés du Bloc québécois si c'est
sièges-là étaient
à gagner pour les parties qui vont
gouverner ce serait pas plus un
on n'aurait pas plus un poids électoral
non parce que du Québec quand même
pousserait mais aussi parce que les
parties
si cette logique là tenait à tout le
moins pour le Parti libéral du Canada
qui a quand même beaucoup de sièges au
Québec
plus
je pense que ce que fait le bloc c'est
de nommer ce qu'il y a pas de bon sens
puis d'en faire un enjeu suffisant pour
que ce soit gênant pour le gouvernement
du Canada d'être aussi peu intéressé par
le Québec donc c'est un autre forme de
rapport de force de dire on va exposer
ce que vous faites soit par rapport au
Québec ou soit par rapport en termes de
corruption ou de manque d'éthique on va
l'exposer très librement et il y aura un
coût politique pour vous à ne pas
collaborer ou à ne pas être adéquat
c'est sûr qu'ultimement vous demanderez
aux gens du bloc puis ils vont vous dire
nous autres qu'on espère c'est que le
Québec devient un pays puis qu'on trouve
pas pris dans un système où tout le
monde nous parle en anglais puis que
tout le monde a une forme de mépris
envers notre action politique
ça me semble être un environnement de
travail vraiment pas évident la Chambre
des communes pour les bloquistes parce
que
leur quotidien c'est celui d'un
gouvernement qui est pas le nôtre
puis qui a peu d'intérêt donc tu te bats
pour chaque truc mais tu te rends compte
que ce soit c'est un univers
puis des intérêts qui correspondent pas
à ce qui sont les nôtres parce que pour
raviver une sorte de Flore indépendante
au Québec ça prendrait un gouvernement
par exemple conservateur de polyèvre par
exemple qui serait tellement plus loin
encore des valeurs
communes québécoises qu'on se dirait que
mais le faux faut vraiment faire quelque
chose ce que j'ai l'impression que
mettons à l'époque de Harper
il y avait il y avait plus une grande au
Québec envers le gouvernement fédéral
que maintenant de de ce que je trouve
peut-être que tu es maintenant d'un
gouvernement fédéral plus de gauche le
type de Saint Trudeau penses-tu que ça
pourrait être bénéfique pratiquement
pour la cause souverainiste d'avoir un
gouvernement conservateur je ne
souhaiterais pas de manière cynique mais
l'histoire est faite de moments
imprévisible pour des événements qui
pour autant sont très prévisibles
donc qu'est-ce qui fait que
tout d'un coup le mur de Berlin chute
qu'est-ce qui fait que tout d'un coup
des événements
comme la naissance de la Slovaquie au
lieu souvent c'est que c'est prévisible
si tu prends un pas de recul en disant
mais c'est clair les intérêts sont pas
les mêmes ça tient pas mais le moment
précis puis la séquence qui mène à ce
moment prévisible et le plus souvent
très imprévisible moi je trouve que la
combinaison le Gau Trudeau est quand
même très bénéfique pour l'indépendance
depuis deux trois ans on voit dans
l'espace public le mot de l'indépendance
du Québec n'existait presque pas dans
l'espace public les chroniques tout ça
il y a 5 ans on voyait rien là ça
revient très souvent pourquoi parce que
le gouvernement Trudeau incarne une
forme de réel mépris envers ce que le
Québec demande et le gouvernement le
goût est comme dans
un corridor pas de porte là comme les
oeillers donc ils répètent toujours la
même erreur le même credo fédéraliste et
il ne reçoivent que des refus puis des
échecs il sentait donc pour n'importe
qui qui regarde ça l'idée de décider par
nous-mêmes devient de plus en plus
évidente donc moi je pense que c'est une
période qui est quand même très
effervescente pour le retour de
l'indépendance comme option considérée
dans les lectorat d'ailleurs on le voit
aussi dans les chiffres
je sais pas ce que ça donnerait avec un
polyèvre dépendamment de la posture
parce qu'il faut les conservateurs sont
moins centralisateurs que les libéraux
ils vont avoir tendance à dire des
choses comme Harper avait dit vous êtes
une nation je vous reconnais comme
nation québécoise
ils ont tendance à être moins
intervient interventionniste dans toutes
nos choses je sais pas qu'est-ce que ça
donnerait c'est quoi il se manifeste
comment c'est mes prix là dont tu parles
du gouvernement Trudeau envers avant le
Québec concrètement dans les actions
c'est le plus souvent c'est François
Legault fait une demande mais avec des
mots très graves là l'avenir de notre
nation c'est fondamentale etc puis le
plus souvent la réponse vient à 24
heures c'est comme une porte que tu fais
mon nid de quelqu'un
il y a même pas de volonté d'enrober
l'absence d'intérêt et le fait que c'est
non on l'a vu notamment pour
l'application de la loi 111 entreprises
à Chartres fédérale on le voit en ce
moment sur Roxane
les pouvoirs en culture les pouvoirs
pour obtenir un seul rapport d'impôts on
fait deux rapports d'impôts c'est un peu
absurde
mais chacune des demandes sont reçus
avec non seulement de l'indifférence
mais une couche de mépris c'est à dire
une réponse le plus souvent à 24 heures
qui témoigne de l'absence de rapport de
force complet
Justin Trudeau est pas si loin de son
père sur le plan idéologique aussi là si
vous retournez aux déclarations de son
père sur ce qu'il pensait du Québec
si vous écoutez certains des députés
libéraux qui siègent au Québec et qui
s'exprime présentement sur le projet de
loi sur les langues officielles ce
qu'ils disent sur la loi 96 ce qu'il
laisse entendre sur le Québec je pense
qu'il y a toujours eu dans le Parti
libéral du Canada un réel mépris pour
les Québécois
et ça changera pas parce que c'est
fondamental
faut revenir aux origines c'est un
régime colonial de domination ça a
toujours été il appelle ça un deux
mignonne mon grand-père il allait pas
faire l'épicerie chez steinburg aller
faire l'épicerie chez dominionne c'est
un territoire conquis
la logique n'a pas tant changé à travers
les années évidemment il y a toute une
couche de relations publiques par dessus
pour que ça paraisse moins mais moi je
ne vois pas d'avenir
je vois aucun avenir en français puis
aucun avenir économique pour les
Québécois si on choisit de demeurer dans
cet ensemble-là à mon avis ce qui nous
attend c'est la même chose que les
francophones au Québec c'est-à-dire une
diminution constante mais certaine
de la proportion de personnes qui
utilisent le français donc avec ça
il y a une culture qui va
qui va disparaître donc c'est un choix
qu'on doit faire entre se prendre en
main exister
s'assumer ou les six déclin-là
mais le francophone au Québec quand même
dans une meilleure posture aujourd'hui
qui l'était probablement dans les années
50 ça c'est quand même fait à
l'intérieur du du Canada dans le sens
qui ont quand même eu des manières de
d'améliorer son sort
à l'intérieur du Canada donc j'imagine
que c'est pas nécessairement ce
mouvement-là peut être traversé quand
même à l'intérieur du Canada
ben c'est comme toujours le même film
c'est un raisonnement qui avait lieu des
années 60 c'est un raisonnement qui a eu
lieu sous bourrassa pour Mitch c'est un
raisonnement que la CAQ fait encore
moi mon constat c'est que tu as raison
de dire que
c'est pas
c'est pas le goulag le Canada la
question par contre c'est est-ce que on
mérite de décider par nous-mêmes ce
qu'on mérite d'exister à l'ONU ce qu'on
mérite d'avoir une équipe de hockey
national est-ce qu'on mérite une
pérennité pour notre langue et notre
culture
toutes ces questions là dans le Canada à
mon avis n'ont aucun avenir donc je
comprends que le Canada ne paye pas nos
maisons puissent pas il y a des régimes
qui sont véritablement des dictatures
d'ailleurs c'est un peu l'habilité du
colonialisme britannique par rapport au
colonialisme français espagnol d'autres
États coloniaux étaient beaucoup plus
violents et dur envers les territoires
qui lui possédaient ce qui amenait la
population a réagir plus vigoureusement
les Britanniques
il y a juste Gandhi en fait c'est pas
n'importe qui là il y a juste grandi qui
a réussi à sortir etterpie un territoire
de l'Empire britannique parce que les
Britanniques finissent par te faire
croire ire non seulement ils sont pas
violents mais finissent par te faire
croire que si tu as une prospérité
si tu as un économie qui a du sens mais
c'est grâce à la grandeur de l'Empire
britannique c'est grâce à ce régime là
si il était pas là
tu es tellement pas adéquate et
tellement pas à la hauteur que ça
fonctionnerait pas et dans les arguments
souvent le mépris qu'un chef du Parti
québécois doit prendre au quotidien
c'est cette conception que si les
Québécois décidaient par eux-mêmes il
serait pas capable d'avoir une économie
prospère il serait pas capable d'offrir
des services alors que notre quotidien
c'est que le Canada comme je vous disais
neuf pas de service puis quand il y en a
comme les passeports c'est une
catastrophe mais c'est faut pas
sous-estimer plus de 200 ans d'histoire
dans notre esprit dans notre mentalité
là l'effet de plus de 200 ans d'histoire
où est-ce qu'on est sous domination
politique économique
ça je pense à altère un peu notre façon
de voir objectivement quelle est notre
intérêt puis c'est ce mon rôle à ce
moment-là de dire mais on peut le voir
d'une autre manière qu'on peut décider
de partir un projet ensemble écrire une
page d'histoire qui ouvre qui offre
toutes sortes de possibilités notamment
pour les nations autochtones également
parce que ça non plus ça bougera pas sur
le Canada alors que si on déclare notre
indépendance mais le lendemain matin on
est libre de négocier d'égal à égal avec
qui on veut puis le Canada plus de mots
à dire là-dedans donc ça ouvre toutes
sortes de possibilités moi j'y crois
beaucoup je pense c'est nécessaire mais
je pense aussi que c'est ce serait
vraiment un bon moment ce sera un moment
qui
rapprocherait les gens
puis là le fun qu'on aurait à exister
internationalement avoir une
reconnaissance tous les niveaux
nous donnerait des décennies
d'effervescence invraisemblable alors
qu'en ce moment c'est c'est morose parce
qu'il faut accepter une forme de déclin
en disant c'est pas si pire
en fait ta question je la résumerai
comme celle-là c'est pas si pire
c'est l'urgence l'urgence de semences
pieds
à une époque où est-ce que les élites
étant anglophones où est-ce qu'il y
avait une proportion anglophone encore
plus grande qu'aujourd'hui
au Québec puis que utile foutuellement
les Canadiens Francis et les petits
peuples le petit piquant dans la misère
l'urgence de la faire de faire ce
mouvement dépendant de cela
[Musique]
la plupart des jeunes j'ai l'impression
qu'il grandissaient à Montréal
francophone mais qui vivent dans un
monde plus de plus en plus
multiculturelle je sais pas à quel point
c'est pas mes convictions à moi mais je
me dis comment comment lui faire voir
l'avantage de l'indépendance finalement
par exemple on envoie plusieurs
milliards de nos impôts en cadeau à des
pétrolières de l'Alberta au lieu de
mettre cet argent-là dans des
entreprises québécoises qui
permettraient de transformer notre
économie pour être zéro émission
c'est sur le Canada
Ottawa est infiltré infiltré par le
lobby pétrolier que ce soit conservateur
ou libéral c'est mieux vraiment
je pense que ces jeunes-là aimeraient ça
qu'on ait une voix à l'ONU puis qu'on
fasse la diplomatie en fonction de ce
qu'on pense et la chose juste à faire à
l'international je pense qu'on triper à
gagner une médaille olympique au hockey
ou dans d'autres domaines puis
ça demeure en termes d'urgence la
période les cinq dix dernières années où
on a mesuré la chute la plus rapide du
français qu'on a jamais mesuré depuis
depuis très longtemps je pense pour
voir la fin du 19e siècle pour voir ce
genre de situation là donc oui urgence
sur le plan linguistique et culturel
parce que le Canada au lieu de
encourager une identité québécoise
partagée au-delà de nos différents
bagages culturels qui ont de la culture
qui ont des connaissances
mais au lieu de dire on est tous
québécois on est tous dans le même
bateau puis on est capable de se
rassembler
parce qu'on est tous québécois le Canada
encourage c'est très identitaire souvent
on taxe le PQ d'être
identitaire l'identité du PQ c'est qu'on
est tous québécois et qu'on a un destin
commun
l'identité canadienne qui est reprise
dans une certaine mesure par QS en fait
pas dans une certaine mesure largement
c'est très identitaire mais c'est de
dire l'identité c'est un groupe
ethnoculturel un groupe religieux un
groupe d'âge une génération compte une
autre un groupe n'importe quel façon de
diviser les gens en sous-groupe c'est
dire c'est ça ton identité puis
méfie-toi de l'identité québécoise
mais c'est pour pour le tissu social
québécois c'est pas saine
il y a une partie où est-ce que je pense
c'est facile de s'entendre que tu veux
pas que des groupes soient discriminés
puis tu veux que des groupes soient
valorisés dans ce qu'ils ont à apporter
mais moi je pense que ça doit quand même
se faire dans une perspective où est-ce
que il y a un moment où on est tous au
même endroit on se reconnaît comme étant
tout ce québécois mais ça c'est très
découragé par le Canada et
à l'Assemblée nationale s'est relayée
par le Parti libéral puis Québec
solidaire qui a mon point de vue donc
sont beaucoup plus identitaires parce
qu'il arrête pas de parler de l'identité
au niveau du genre au niveau
ethnoculturel puis rarement un Québec
solidaire il y a plus d'espace pour des
bannières marxiste les ministres qu'il y
en a pour le drapeau du Québec
c'est pas normal le drapeau du Québec
c'est pas négatif c'est un rappel qu'on
est tous québécois puis qu'on a une
responsabilité les uns envers les autres
donc moi j'étais on peut dire juste un
social-démocrate c'est à dire que je
pense que c'est important que tout le
monde a des services on veut le moins
d'inégalités sociales le moins
criminalité le moins de problèmes
sociaux
mais pour avoir l'empathie ou le sens
des responsabilités envers des gens que
tu connais pas au point de payer des
impôts élevés
mais il faut que tu aies un sentiment
d'appartenance un sentiment d'empathie
envers les autres si tu as juste un
sentiment individualiste ou
communautaire magent puis le reste ça
m'intéresse pas mais ça crée un climat
social qui est à mon avis est moins
responsable envers les autres
c'est un modèle dans lequel je crois pas
mais je pense qu'il faut
encourager le plus possible les gens à
être au même endroit puis bâtir sur ce
qu'ils ont en commun des choses de base
mais le Français
je pense que plusieurs gens personnes
qui viennent au Québec dans ce que tu
décris comme multiculturel mais ils
viennent au Québec parce que c'est
francophone donc on peut rassembler
plein de gens autour de ça mais il faut
se donner la mission de rassembler non
pas de catégoriser les gens par
sous-groupe
c'est difficile de parler de on dirait
de d'identité puis d'identité
québécoises puis de souveraineté sans
rapidement
certaines personnes se faire accoler des
étiquettes comme raciste par exemple
c'est le code René Lévesque à la base
depuis le début de ce mouvement là
Parisot Marwa mais les chefs du parti
québécois et le mouvement c'est toujours
faite à coller toutes sortes
d'étiquettes ça ça depuis la fondation
évidemment que le racisme existe au
Québec puis que c'est fondamental de
respecter ses libertés religieuse
mais comment qu'on fait comment qu'on
trouve l'équilibre finalement entre
intégration puis
assimilation parce que si on veut pas
non plus
complètement détruire l'identité de
quelqu'un qui arriverait ici ou de leur
culture comment comment
on trouve chez la démocratie c'est à
dire que tu laisses les gens en discuter
puis tu travailles sur des consensus qui
sont tout le temps en train d'évoluer
maintenant ce qui arrive dans le régime
canadien c'est que c'est souvent le
Canada à travers notamment les tribunaux
qui décident de ce qui est acceptable ou
ce qui l'est pas et ça vient avec le
phénomène du Québec bashing à chaque
fois que le Québec a tenté de donner une
réponse différente de celle du Canada
sur ces questions là ça vient avec un
backlash là mais vraiment
une réponse violente du reste du Canada
prend la laïcité qui le débat de
division par excellence depuis
maintenant presque 15 ans
je pense que c'est à la base deux
sociétés qui n'ont pas la même
définition du droit à la religion
pour le Canada le droit à la religion
c'est un droit vraiment suprême en toute
circonstances au point ou même si le
code de la route te dit de porter un
casque mais si tu as un signe religieux
ça aurait préséance d'un débat qui a eu
lieu en Ontario mais ça aurait presque
sur la sécurité routière mais le signe
religieux le religieux dans l'espace
public surtout ce Trudeau
a vraiment une importante
à mes yeux démesurés donc c'est une
définition extrêmement large du droit à
la religion alors qu'au Québec je dis
n'importe qui que suivi un peu
l'histoire du Québec c'est que les
Québécois
Satan à ce qu'on se garde une petite
gêne sur la question des convictions
religieuses pense à travers leur
expérience du catholicisme mais
également l'observation de plusieurs
pays qui ont connu des guerres pour ces
questions là n'importe qui va à
Jérusalem supposons se promener
comprendra que des gens qui sont
fondamentalistes
sur le plan religieux et ça peu importe
la religion mais ça crée un
environnement qui est vraiment pas le
fun très tendu entre chacune de ces
religions-là donc l'attente des
Québécoises des Québécois c'est de dire
nous notre droit à la religion c'est que
tout le monde peut aller dans un temple
puis prier puis ça c'est bien correct
mais on s'attend à ce que dans l'espace
public les gens se gardent une petite
gêne en tout cas si c'est quelqu'un en
autorité qui qui représente l'état on a
déjà joué dans le film où l'État et la
religion ne faisait qu'un on regarde ce
qui se passe dans plein de régime où
l'État et la religion ne font qu'un puis
on est vraiment désaccord donc on
s'attend à ce que le droit à la religion
soit défini de manière plus concise
et là ben vient des lobés financés par
le gouvernement fédéral pour nous dire
que c'est du racisme et il faut voir
aussi comment la gauche radicale c'est
quand même imposée depuis 10 ans
des idées qui sont somme toutes
démocrates et républicaine républicaine
pas au sens américain le métier une idée
de citoyenneté égalité fraternité de
base et rapidement aujourd'hui catalogué
comme étant de droite ou d'extrême
droite prenez axe c'est vraiment
intéressant
je pense que je pense que ceux qui est
juste roxment c'est un exemple fascinant
de ce que j'essaie d'expliquer sur la
place de la gauche radicale dans
l'environnement universitaire et
médiatique dans une certaine mesure
Roxane c'est une brèche dans la
frontière qui permet à quiconque qui
veut rentrer au Québec de rentrer au
Québec il y a pas de critère
d'évaluation il y a pas de et on sait
qu'on est même pas 9 millions et qui a
plus de 900 millions de personnes au sud
de la frontière dans les Amériques au
complet
donc
c'est d'abolir les frontières dont il
est question
c'est si tu laisses passer un nombre
illimité de personnes
t'abolie des factotes et frontières et
c'est une idée très radicale parce que
la social-démocratie peut pas fournir
des services puis des logements pour un
homme illimité de personnes parce que la
démocratie présuppose qu'un nombre
déterminé de personnes sur un territoire
déterminé se donne un destin collectif
commun puis ça donne un c'est très
radical l'abolition des frontières
on va cataloguer tous ceux qui pensent
pas comme nous comme étant d'extrême
droite alors que il y a rien de plus
centriste que dire on devrait accueillir
en fonction de notre capacité d'accueil
puis donc ça va prendre des frontières
un processus ordonné de traitement des
demandes on peut pas juste ouvrir la
frontière puis dire il y en a plus
mais c'est un renversement des
étiquettes ou des idées radicales sont
présentées comme la voix de l'empathie
le pont a l'air du signalement moral
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de d'émotions
là-dedans et ceux qui remettent en
question l'idée radicale se font traiter
de radicaux ou d'extrémistes ce qui n'a
aucun sens fait qu'il faut prendre la
mesure aussi de comment l'espace public
se transforme puis rend difficile c'est
déballons qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
quelqu'un rentre au Canada par le chemin
Roxane pour ces personnes
ben pour l'instant c'est très
c'est pas clair
comme là on a appris dans les dernières
semaines que là il y avait un certain
nombre des milliers de personnes qui
avaient été redirigées vers l'Ontario
plus c'est le maire de Niagara Falls qui
est sorti pour dire on n'est pas capable
mais il y a des policiers qui sont là il
y a quand même un oui parce que
rendu officiel je veux dire là on est
rendu où tu as des passeurs criminels
qui présentent une demande de réfugiés
comme étant la manière d'être reçue
comme immigrants au Canada
ils exploitent financièrement l'un des
gens pour passer ce périple là l'État de
New York s'est mis à payer les billets
d'autobus pour que les migrants qui sont
aux États-Unis transit vers le Québec
et du côté du Canada des donateurs du
Parti libéral du Canada ont obtenu des
contrats sans appel d'offres pour
institutionnaliser en permanent
l'accueil à travers Roxane donc c'est
fondamentalement anti-démocratique c'est
à dire que Trudeau nous impose une
abolition effective des frontières sans
qu'il y ait eu de débats et sans qu'on
ait un mot à dire donc vous comprenez
que quand je vois François Legault qui
est notre premier ministre demandez un
tweet à Justin Trudeau il y a un moment
donné je dis aux gens le prenant un peu
de recul les posons-nous la question
est-ce que tout ça est normal est-ce que
c'est normal que des décisions une
planification qui devrait être ordonner
de des choix de société qu'on veut faire
en matière d'accueil notamment de
logements de service de français est-ce
que c'est normal que ça soit
court-circuité
par une mesure aussi radicale que
l'abolition de nos frontières par un
gouvernement que moi je remet en
question constamment donc que tout le
monde ici s'entend pour dire qu'on n'a
pas les capacités d'accueillir mais on
en a des capacités d'accueil puis vous
remarquerez que les Québécois sont fiers
d'accueillir des réfugiés comme c'était
pour la série l'Ukraine moi je pense que
démocratiquement les Québécoises et les
Québécois vont choisir d'accueillir des
réfugiés et c'est tant mieux
mais c'est parce que c'est une décision
démocratique qui est planifiée puis là
on accueille les gens puis on s'arrange
pour que ce soit un succès pour que ce
soit humain pour que ce soit viable
lorsqu'on a en ce moment là c'est un
débordement au niveau de du logement des
services
on a plein de reportages de situations
qui sont inacceptables sur le plan
justement de l'humanité de la
puis je crains également que la
social-démocratie le notre idée de payer
des impôts en échange d'avoir des
services
ne tiennent pas le coup si un homme
important de personnes
arrivent puis demandent des services
alors qu'on a déjà de la difficulté à
livrer du logement social en quantité
suffisante peut livrer des services de
santé d'éducation qui soit acceptable
à tout le moins on devra un débattre
puis moi ça me dérange pas de débattre
avec des gens qui disent de non on fait
pas assez notre effort il faut en
accueillir plus ok parlons-en puis on
délibère il y a pas de bonne réponse
mais au moins on va en débattre mais là
c'est zéro démocratique c'est Justin
Trudeau qui lui est dans une idéologie
lunaire lui il veut 100 millions de
Canadiens pour 2100
donc c'est une vision du Canada qui a
été conçue avec Mackenzie un ancienne
mécanisé qui s'appelle
leur vision du Millénaire ou la
population du Canada explose dans un
modèle d'immigration très massive
les prémices de pourquoi faudrait faire
ça c'est pas très clair mais ça c'est la
vision canadienne comme il y a une
certaine époque aux États-Unis ouais
mais ça c'était pas planifié c'était
vraiment des migrations venant d'Europe
en raison de situation entre autres les
maladies des patates les patates étaient
les récoltes étaient complètement
périmés en Irlande en Suède là on parle
ici d'une planification volontaire
mais qui donne presque pas de chance aux
Français par la culture québécoise parce
que là c'est comme des propos des
proportions
en tout cas c'est improbable qui a une
pérennité linguistique et culturelle
dans le modèle que Justin Trudeau
cherche à nous imposer mais moi ce qui
me chatouille le plus là dedans c'est
qu'il y a pas de débat
ça nous est imposé de manière effective
puis toute personne qui le roman
question mais là la technique que je
parlais de la gauche radicale mais on le
voit dans plusieurs universités c'est
vraiment de stigmatiser d'intimider
toute personne qui remet en question ce
qui est en train de d'arriver
donc ça devient même un devoir pour la
démocratie de s'assurer que
même si la pression est forte puis
rapidement on va utiliser des épithètes
comme xénophobe extrême droite pour des
gens qui sont absolument centrés ou
sociales démocrate ça devient un devoir
d'imposer le débat puis de pas se
laisser intimider parce que sinon c'est
quoi le bout de ça les des idées qui
s'imposent par l'intimidation en
s'assurant qu'il y a pas de débat c'est
très mal simple ça peut nous mener en
tout cas l'histoire de l'Occident nous
dit que ce genre d'approche là peut nous
donner très très loin donc moi je le
prends au sérieux mais n'empêche que la
question se pose quand même de qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les gens qui cognent à
notre porte qui ont qui fut la guerre
par exemple ou que c'est qui qui fut les
attestés puis qui veulent venir ici je
veux pas
Québec on vit dans un certain confort
puis je dis moi puis tout le monde ici
on est né au Québec un peu par chance ça
a donné qu'on est né ici qu'on vit un
certain niveau de vie la question se
pose quand même je veux dire des gens
qui arrivent ici avec
qui ont juste tirer un coup de dés moins
favorable qu'est-ce qu'on fait que ces
gens-là définition premièrement la
différence entre l'immigration
économique et les réfugiés pour la
guerre
les gens qui passent à Roxane plusieurs
d'entre eux cherchent à améliorer leur
sort économique puis je lis blanc pas
mais ce sont pas nécessairement des cas
comme la Syrie puis l'Ukraine
donc
se pose la question de fond
est-ce que
sur le plan de l'immigration économique
supposons que je vous parlais de plus de
900 millions de personnes combien sur
ces presque milliards de personnes en
Amérique améliorer son sort économique
en venant vivre au Québec la moitié
probablement une grosse partie 500
millions
est-ce que c'est un modèle pour
combattre la pauvreté que de tenter
d'accueillir des millions de personnes
au Québec
est-ce que c'est un modèle qui est le
bon pour combattre la pauvreté ou est-ce
que
il y a une part de signalement moral
là-dedans où est-ce que nos efforts de
développement international de
redistribution des richesses entre les
sociétés riches et les sociétés en voie
de développement sont animés sont très
pauvres sont fait pas d'efforts mais on
va accueillir des quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes alors que si on
prend le standard de pauvreté québécois
mais là
ça s'améliore la pauvreté dans le monde
mais c'est encore criant et ça se compte
par milliards le par centaines de
millions
finalement je pense que on a une
responsabilité morale
de soutenir les pays qui
se font exploiter ou se sont fait
exploiter ça nous permet d'avoir un
dollar à main ou toute une pièce mais on
a une responsabilité
socio-économique envers eux
mais je pense que
je suis assez confiant qu'on va
continuer à cueillir
des gens des réfugiés qui ont besoin
mais faut pas se leurrer sur le fait que
c'est une solution à la pauvreté dans le
monde on les prend pas nos
responsabilités en matière de lutte à la
pauvreté dans le monde on les prend très
faiblement
donc
je fais juste dire que le modèle de
l'immigration n'est peut-être pas la
réponse la plus
ambitieuse si on veut vraiment que des
gens qui vont demeurer dans leur pays
d'origine
vivent dans un niveau
acceptable sur le plan de la pauvreté
puis en même temps je reviens mon idée
de base c'est que c'est une discussion
démocratique
j'ai eu une discussion justement j'étais
une manifestation pour le logement
social puis il y a une militante qui est
venue me reprocher mes positions sur
Roxane puis j'ai dit oui mais vous en
fait vous prenez l'abolition des
frontières a dit oui il faut abolir les
frontières puis je lui ai dit mais je
viens de demander à François Legault en
chambre 45000 logements sociaux sur cinq
ans puis ça c'est très ambitieux je
l'obtiendrai pas parce que la caca peut
d'intérêt pour ces questions là mais
même si je bâtis 45000 logements sociaux
sur 5 ans ça fait toujours bien un peu
moins de 10000 par année qu'est-ce que
je fais si j'ai un afflu un afflux de
cent mille personnes
et où la mathématique là j'essaie de
comprendre
donc
c'est des questions qui sont délicates
parce que on parle ici de modèles
d'immigration de modèles de décision
démocratique
mes adversaires vont rapidement
transformer ça en une attaque contre des
personnes c'est ça la faire c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile de
maintenir la discussion à un niveau de
politique publique parce que rapidement
il y aura plusieurs histoires touchantes
de gens qui tentent de traverser parce
que Justin Trudeau a envoyé un tweet en
disant vous êtes bienvenus
et leurs histoires elles sont très
touchantes tu souhaites leur succès mais
oui mais en même temps il faut voir
quelle est la résultante de ces
politiques là
dépendamment du choix qu'on veut faire
ou pas puis moi ma seule demande à ce
stade-ci c'est qu'on soit capable de
regarder chaque côté de des options
devant nous puis qu'on soit capable d'en
parler mais juste ça j'y arrive
difficilement
parce que je me fais traiter une chance
pour moi le sujet pas le profil le plus
agressif ou le plus intolérant dans la
vie mais même ça les insultes surtout
Twitter là qui l'environnement le plus
toxique puis le plus de personnes qui
est positif qui commandent sur Twitter
le monde positif ils lisent le truc ils
ont une pensée
c'est le monde taxé qui prennent le
temps qu'il y a beaucoup de
désinformations toutes sortes de ce fils
par association de la propagande qui se
répète alors que c'est pas vrai puis
écoute c'est pour dire que ça vient
aussi peut-être avec les médias sociaux
l'incapacité il y avait un super
reportage aux États-Unis
qui disait que la polarisation est
rendue tellement forte aux États-Unis
que le camp démocrate souhaite la mort
du camp républicain et vice versa
l'autisme complètement et vraiment une
proportion élevée autour de 80% pense
que l'autre camp est juste imbécile
six rendu donc probablement aussi qu'une
des difficultés qu'on a
c'est que les médias sociaux nous
donnent très peu d'espace de discussions
posées
puis c'est là que toutes les épithètes
embarquent rapidement parce que tu veux
disqualifier ton adversaire fait que tu
le traites de quelque chose tu le
répètes tout le temps puis à un moment
donné mais les gens disent en tout cas
lui se fait souvent qui se fait traiter
de 600 ça doit être vrai c'est plate
mais la propagande fonctionne comme ça
moi je pense qu'une menace à la
démocratie
[Musique]
c'est de réconcilier l'idée
surtout dans parce que Roxane c'est
juste ça c'est juste à ça qu'on que je
pense quand je pense c'est de
réconcilier l'expérience humaine avec
l'idée plus macro de du Québec comme
comme société avec une culture vraiment
distincte parce que quand les deux gars
qui sont allés à Tout le monde en parle
la semaine passée tu entends leur
histoire qui sont passés par vaccent tu
fais comme comme tu disais c'était
touchant tellement touchante des
citoyens tellement modèle que tu dis
genre yes c'est plus plus de gens comme
ça
Radio-Canada ne s'est pas donné beaucoup
d'efforts pour s'assurer qu'il y a un
dialogue avec tous les côtés de la
médaille justement tu prends deux
personnes qui méritent entièrement c'est
qu'on veut au Québec puis c'est très
touchant puis je
je partage mais en même temps vous
remarquerez que il y a pas
l'autre côté le de combien de discuter à
savoir si l'an prochain c'est pas 40 000
mais c'est plusieurs dizaines ou
centaines milliers de plus de personnes
qu'on n'est pas capable de construire du
logement qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait c'est des questions de base
comme celle-là n'ont pas été posées et
dans certains éditoriaux
donc
je souhaiterais qu'il y ait un
traitement
disons que les médias sont de plus en
plus prévisibles dépendamment de quel
média parle c'est pas mal comment ils
vont traiter la question et je pense
qu'un diffuseur public parce qu'on paie
des impôts pour Radio-Canada or la
responsabilité d'un débat équilibré et
non pas d'un débat
orienté sur le plan
idéologique au point où clairement on
veut une seule version
c'est parce que c'est
c'est difficile parce que la discussion
sur le modèle viable et durable sur le
plan de la langue et des services du
logement elle est difficile à juxtaposer
avec la discussion sur le véhicule de
chaque personne qui souhaite améliorer
son sort en venant au Québec
mais moi je pense quand même qu'il faut
réussir à faire les deux c'est à dire
accueillir dignement toute personne
qu'on accueille être empathique être
respectueux mais également être capable
de nommer certaines questions évidentes
qu'on vient de nommer justement
puis j'ai vu que
de dire mais au lieu de se dire il y a
un chemin non officiel par lequel les
gens peuvent rentrer faire mon ça puis
faisons juste à n'importe quel frontière
c'est une solution qui est tout à fait 5
ans que le Parti québécois demande ça
mais c'est que elle joue sur les deux
tableaux comme ils le font souvent ils
vont dire on veut la suspension de
l'Entente puis justement met à profit
tous les postes frontaliers mais ils
savent très bien que ça fait cinq six
ans que Justin Trudeau n'entend pas
donc le Parti québécois va un peu plus
loin en disant mais là ça fait 6 ans si
il y avait une volonté politique une
bonne foi de renégocier tout ça on le
saurait donc on va augmenter la pression
d'une coche puis on va intervenir avec
les pouvoirs qu'on a à Roxane de manière
à forcer une discussion avec Justin
Trudeau mais là à ce moment-là QS va
déformer on va dire pspp s'en prend
moi je parle d'immigration je parle du
modèle ils vont utiliser le mot
immigrants ils vont faire des
juxtaposition avec des enfants des ils
vont vraiment jouer
démonisés la volonté d'aller au bout du
raisonnement et eux vont se cacher
derrière juste intrudo c'est à dire
juste un Trudeau n'a pas l'intention de
faire quoi que ce soit ça fait 6 ans que
ça dure et c'est un peu parce que le
Parti québécois a décidé de augmenter la
pression sur Ottawa que là le débat
s'impose de manière plus vous me direz
trop là pour nous c'est difficile des
fois parce qu'il y a des plans de
presque tu veux parler de d'autres
choses puis là les 400 viennent toujours
la question revient à tous
c'est beaucoup j'ouvre mon twitter ce
n'est que Roxane puis c'est difficile de
que ça me donne pas ça parce qu'il y a
un appétit médiatique très réel pour ces
questions là probablement parce que les
algorithmes comme les codes d'écoute
réagissent fortement lorsque n'importe
quoi
quelque chose que tous les partis
politiques prendre depuis maintenant 5
ans ils savent très bien que ça
fonctionne pas mais se cache derrière ça
tout en disant des choses comme mais ça
donne rien de fermer Roxane parce que
les gens vont passer ailleurs donc ils
disent une chose et son contraire parce
que leur approche en est une de
signalement moral et c'est différent
signaler ta vertu c'est différent que tu
cherches une solution dans le monde réel
puis chercher une solution dans le monde
réel ça amène des critiques parce que la
politique réelle a des contraintes
est imparfaite de la proposition du
Parti québécois parce qu'une
intervention de la SQ c'est pas une
solution permanente c'est une façon de
forcer
d'avoir un rapport de force un moyen de
pression vis-à-vis Ottawa
elle est imparfaite mais c'est de la
politique réelle c'est à dire on
constate que ça fait cinq six ans que ça
bouge pas puis on veut se réapproprier
nos choix démocratiques dans cette
domaine-là puis
Ottawan nous ne nous le permet pas mais
c'est là que toute la politique
partisanale et identitaire des parties
qui se disent contre l'identitaire en
barque c'est à dire qu'ils vont déformer
tes propos ils vont jouer sur
c'est du signalement moral est-ce que
des chemins roxanes est-ce qu'il y a des
équivalents dans les autres provinces
canadiennes ou c'est vraiment au Québec
c'est surtout au Québec 99% des entrées
régulières on est au
québecs de la côte Est américaine et
propice là c'est très populaire de New
York Boston
mais également c'est que
Justin Trudeau a intentionnellement
fait de Roxane un endroit où passer donc
ce qui illégal ou irrégulier devient
normalisé standard
il y a bâti des infrastructures autour
en disant
on vous attend c'est ceux que sont tweet
disait donc c'est sûr que lorsqu'on
normalise quelque chose qui est
irrégulier on a beau dire c'est pas se
poser comme ça les gens surtout les
passeurs qui eux font du recrutement
pour se faire de l'argent mais
identifie ça donc le tu es rendu quand
en Turquie il y a des reportages qui
disent si vous allez au Canada vous
passez par les États-Unis vous rentrez
puis
plein de choses gratuites c'est vraiment
un amélioration de vos conditions de vie
mais imaginez si chacun des continents
du monde envoie ce message là et que
Roxanne devient le point d'entrer parce
que il y a des milliards de personnes
sur la terre donc on est même pas 9
millions
bref moi je pense qu'il y a une forme si
on faisait des efforts sérieux pour
combattre la pauvreté réglementer les
pays qui sont exploités par des
multinationales redistribuer les
ressources pour que des gens n'aient pas
à prendre tous ces risques là puis se
déraciner pour obtenir un avenir
intéressant pour leurs enfants si on
faisait ses efforts là je ne trouverai
plus cohérent mais
on a vraiment un double discours comme
société à plusieurs égards
puis moi je
je mène le débat le mieux que je peux
attendez-vous à ce que je souhaite
toujours responsable mais je suis pas
dupe de ce qui arrive historiquement au
chef du Parti québécois qui ose
s'aventurer sur ces questions là il y a
tout un joutes
pour chacun des chefs depuis l'histoire
de ce parti-là de démoniser ce qui en
fait parfaitement normal c'est à dire
avoir une frontière avoir un processus
démocratique de détermination de combien
de personnes comment les accueille avoir
une cérémonie d'accueil québécoise
n'oubliez pas que en ce moment c'est le
Canada qui accueille ils se font dire
tes Canadiens c'est grâce au Canada ça
devrait être québécoise
canadien je deviens canadien
dans l'esprit la plupart des gens qui
viennent au Québec qui immigré au Canada
jusqu'à que je veux
en France mon accent et ça vous êtes
canadien c'est tout c'est toujours puis
dans l'esprit pas dans l'esprit mais
dans ce qu'on leur présente le Canada ce
sont des communautés culturelles puis
les Kebs ben c'est une communauté
culturelle résiduelle sont là
sont là pour combien de temps on le sait
pas parce qu'on connaît la courbe mais
c'est une des communautés culturelles
mais
comme québécois je vois pas pourquoi on
accepte très ça alors qu'on pourrait
avoir notre propre pays puis dire à ceux
qui choisissent d'être Québécois mais
bienvenue tes québécois on est québécois
puis on décide ensemble point barre
on n'est pas des communautés culturelles
puis on a chacun un vote puis on paye
chacun nos impôts
mais c'est
ça crée un climat et je trouve de
dévalorisation même de peur envers les
Québécois c'est vraiment le
[Musique]
il y a une
identité envers le Canada qui est comme
une forme de protection envers ce que
les Québécois pourraient faire comme la
laïcité mais c'est une telle
démonisation de démarches qui me semble
parfaitement légitime parce qu'on le
voit dans d'autres pays les mêmes
démarches les mêmes raisonnements qui
est propre à notre histoire aussi qui
nous ressemble parce qu'on a vécu
certaines choses parce qu'on a une
conception au Téléjournal c'était une
nouvelle affaire dans des
orphelinats où est-ce que c'était des
religieuses qui ont qui ont agressé
sexuellement des enfants au Saguenay
puisque cette semaine là j'écoutais ça
puis je me disais
la laïcité et critiquée sous prétexte
que ça attaque certaines religions n'est
pas juste mais c'est que ça attaque
principalement notre histoire notre
histoire vis-à-vis de la religion mais
aussi c'est parce que
ça met beaucoup en lumière des gens qui
sont très très fervents de la religion
c'est une approche plus fondamentaliste
à la religion et ça contraint aussi
lance des critiques des musulmans des
juifs ou des athées qui sont largement
majoritaires et qui ont une relation
avec la religion qui est beaucoup plus à
mon avis saine beaucoup plus prudente
donc tu as des groupes de pression
financiers le plus souvent par le
fédéral qui nous donne l'impression que
la diversité culturelle c'est aussi
d'être très très très très commis envers
la religion puis d'être déclare la
religion joue un rôle dans ta vie là qui
est illimité alors que quand on regarde
la composition de l'immigration qu'on
reçoit au Québec mais il y en a
plusieurs qui fuient des régimes
ultra-religieux puis qui veulent
absolument rien savoir puis il y a
plusieurs personnes qui arrivent qui
sont athées puis ils veulent juste vie
dans une société où est-ce qu'il y a une
paix sociale donc notre démarche
je pense qu'elle représente beaucoup
plus de monde
que ce que les médias relais parce que
les médias relaient les groupes de
pression qui eux ont des attaques très
très rapides dépressives
un peu ce qu'on disait tantôt démoniser
pour tenter de neutraliser
il y a quand même une je pense je peux
pas faire la diable mais je pense que
quand même une certaine époque où est-ce
que la religion était avait le pouvoir
était dominante on a voulu l'évacuer
versus aujourd'hui où est-ce que la
majorité le pouvoir est pas religieux
puis le combat des lois sur
les jeux par exemple une enseignante
t'es pas très drôle ça je pense pas que
ça mais
en péril la laïcité je pense pas que ça
nous rebelle dans une position où est-ce
que
l'État et les religieux devient ça
dépend ce que les parents pensent
si ton fils toi tu viens d'une famille
qui vraiment attire
ton fils va à l'école puis
l'enseignant ou l'enseignante est
tellement proche de ses convictions
religieuses qu'il n'est pas capable de
considérer d'enlever son signe religieux
le temps d'être avec des enfants de
confessions différentes puis avec des
enfantés
ça dépend ce que les parents en pensent
parce qu'en démocratie
l'opinion de chacun puis comment il
perçoit l'enjeu devrait être considéré
donc non moi je suis pas sûr si
plusieurs positions l'État joue un rôle
tellement important le quantité de Dieu
quand tu confies tes enfants à l'état
l'État joue un rôle vraiment important
donc de dire que c'est trop demandé de
séparer la religion puis des
interventions de l'État comme celui-là
ou comme un policier ou un jeu
partout parce que j'ai eu mais les
réponses différentes à se débat là si tu
regardes les pays en Europe en Amérique
mais aussi
que certains individus religieux au sein
de l'État fait nous sommes de ça un état
religieux
comme ça l'été une certaine époque non
en effet c'est pas l'époque prix
Révolution tranquille mais se pose quand
même la question légitime de où est-ce
qu'on trouve que le religieux ne devrait
pas se mélanger avec l'intervention de
l'État puis ça les gens ont leur mot à
dire les parents les intervenants c'est
pour ça qu'on essaie d'avoir un débat
mais là ça fait quand même 15 ans qu'on
a ce débat là je pense qu'on a fait le
tour de tous les arguments de part et
d'autre puis comme n'importe quoi en
démocratie les réponses sont imparfaites
c'est à dire que tu peux pas avoir 100%
des gens qui en viennent à la même
conclusion et le plus souvent c'est des
espèces de
compromis donc elle est pas parfaite la
loi 21 sous plusieurs égards je suis
premier à le dire
mais c'est un peu le c'est un peu ça la
démocratie aussi là c'est de faire des
compromis à certains endroits puis
bref
c'est une question
pour moi je m'avais pas entendu parler
de ça en campagne électorale pourquoi
parce que je considère que c'est une
question qui était largement débattue et
qui est pas déterminante pour notre
avenir comme les celles des la question
climatique puis la question linguistique
donc c'est une question parmi tant
d'autres à mes yeux
on parlait la semaine passée je te
disais que des fois quand je fais
beaucoup de voitures je m'imagine à Tout
le monde en parle avec Guillaume qui me
pose des questions pour essayer de
réfléchir à voix haute sur des trucs
puis là je réfléchissais à parce que
j'ai des amis autour de moi qui
consomment pas de culture québécoises
puis que la question de la culture
on dirait ensemble perdre en importance
avec la globalisation de toutes les
services de streaming puis de comme on
parlait un petit peu avant de il y a
plus de on s'assoit on regarde la belle
la petite vie est revenue mais on
s'assoit et on a quelque chose de commun
qu'on construit ensemble tu peux avoir
accès à toutes les artistes du monde
entier sur Spotify qui est vraiment un
espèce de la culture s'effrite
tranquillement
puis je me disais comment essayer de
d'expliquer parce que moi je suis très
attaché à la culture québécoise parce
que j'ai été
je suis peut-être un petit peu plus
vieux que les gens qui désintéressent
complètement mais j'ai aussi été élevé
dans dans une famille où est-ce qu'on
consommait beaucoup de musique
québécoises de films québécois ce genre
de choses là j'ai essayé de me dire
comment est-ce que je peux
expliquer à ces amis là ou du moins
faire-part de ma fierté de québécoise à
ses amis là déjà si tu te rends là c'est
comme le premier but baseball tu t'es
rendu sur les bus et c'est déjà une
contribution substantielle mais je te
dirais un faut pas se décourager moi je
parlais avec Paul Piché avant-hier puis
il me disait après la défaite
référendaire de René Lévesque en 80
dans les années 80 c'était tellement pas
à la mode la culture québécoise que
juste de chanter en français c'était
quasiment impossible c'était mal reçu
il dit j'ai eu besoin de beaucoup de
courage pour chanter en français mais
c'est pas le Piché qui dit bon fait
qu'il y a eu des moments très récents où
on pensait que la culture québécoise
n'aurait pas de place puis d'un coup est
revenu
on prend en parler ça vaut la peine
d'enjaser entre amis mais de mon point
de vue c'est vraiment le problème d'un
goût d'un gouvernement qui
n'est pas ses culottes qui prend pas ses
responsabilités dans ce secteur là
tu peux pas avoir une culture québécoise
vigoureuse si tu as soutiens pas parce
que
le raz-de-marée est tellement fort puis
le l'argent qui a derrière ça
tellement
évident que ton petit marché québécois
si tu as simplement une logique
d'affaires c'est à dire est-ce qu'on met
une pièce ça va me rapporter si je fais
telle série si tu veux compétitionner en
termes de qualité
puis essayez d'être rentable il va y
avoir certains cas de succès mais c'est
pas un modèle
l'État québécois doit embarquer dire ben
nous dans nos priorités la même manière
qu'on privilégie l'éducation puis la
santé la culture québécoise elle est
soutenue est en promotion constante
et les artistes québécois donc ont une
manière de gagner leur vie intéressante
souvenons-nous que dans les belles
années vous êtes plus jeune mais dans
les années où est-ce qu'on allait au
magasin disque ben il y avait un modèle
d'affaires de d'aller chercher des
profits assez explicite là c'est que tu
vends un record tu vas un album puis
l'homme est un album il est platine puis
ça ça veut dire que tu as fait une cote
à chaque album donc tu auras assez de
l'argent quand la révolution
technologique fait en sorte que tout
ceux disparaissait
on n'a jamais retrouvé un modèle
d'affaires qui soit viable pour les
artistes québécois qui soient
acceptables mais c'est l'État québécois
c'est le gouvernement qui aurait dû
réagir en disant attention il y a une
transformation comment moi ce que je
réagis pour m'assurer que nos créateurs
québécois soit dans un modèle tout aussi
intéressant qu'auparavant il sait pas
fait grand chose dans ce domaine-là
c'est le bout le plus fâche pour moi
parce qu'après
François Legault a juste à dire et moi
je suis fier d'être Québécois quand tu
cas je veux que mes petits-enfants
parlent français c'est comme si les gens
ils sont comme ah ben là franchement ils
s'en occupent mais moi je la vois cette
jolie politique là sur la culture et
c'est un peu comme la préservation du
patrimoine on fait très peu en ce moment
c'est service minimum mais on renfloue
ça par des déclarations
qui fait en sorte que les gens qui ont
pas beaucoup de temps pour regarder
chaque détail de ces politiques
publiques là ils se disent la cacahuité
pour eux mais c'est pas le cas donc ça
va prendre pour relancer la culture
québécoise et moi je pense que ce que tu
dis là plusieurs personnes le ressentent
ressentent une forme de désolation de
voir la culture québécoise et la langue
française en recul si on arrive avec des
politiques fortes de soutien
ça peut reprendre très rapidement parce
qu'on le veut des années 80 on a vu des
cycles
d'americanisation même là quand les
artistes québécois là je veux pas me
tromper parce que j'étais pas né mais
tes années 50
75 les artistes québécois reprenaient
des succès américains puis le traduisait
de créativité qui est pas du tout celui
de Beau Dommage qui parle de notre âme
qui parle de qui on est il y a eu des
retours de balancier dans l'histoire du
Québec et moi je c'est une des premières
choses que je vais faire c'est pas la
chose la plus payante électoralement
j'ai essayé de parler de culture pendant
la campagne puis le titre de l'article
c'est pspp veut la fin de la
pat'patrouille c'était une catastrophe
c'était pas ça que j'avais vu
alors que j'annonçais j'annonçais un
rossement substantiel en culture en
notamment pour les émissions jeunesse on
devrait avoir des émissions de qualité
québécoises plutôt que d'acheter des
bébés pleins de couleurs puis de bruit
là qui rendent peut-être nos enfants
hypnotisés pendant 30 minutes mais les
faits sur leur développement là moi je
trouve ça assez douteux ça finit que je
voulais la fin de la pat'patrouille donc
je suis très
conscient que c'est difficile de gagner
des points dans les sondages avec la
culture mais ici on m'en donne la chance
une des premières choses que je vais
faire c'est complètement changer le
modèle culturel parce que mon projet ma
raison d'être en politique qui est
l'idée que nous serons un pays
un jour dépend largement de cette
existence culturelle au-delà de la
réglementation sur la langue la langue
témoigne d'une culture d'une conception
du monde d'une histoire d'un avenir
qu'on a en commun puis tout ça est
véhiculé par la culture donc c'est les
deux éléments qui rassemble le plus les
gens à part la bouffe c'est le sport
puis la culture c'est ça voir l'équipe
Québec gagné il y a rien de plus
rassembleur puis aller entendre un
artiste qui témoigne de notre vision du
monde il y a rien de plus rassembleur
donc c'est là-dedans qu'il faut aller si
on veut rassembler des gens au lieu des
diviser ce que ce que j'essaie de faire
avec ses amis là justement puis c'est ça
que je te parlais c'est que c'est
d'extraire toutes les exemples
de glorification du Canada à
l'international
par des Québécois pour essayer de leur
faire comprendre à quel point ce serait
incroyable si vraiment on pouvait
s'approprier le succès de ces gens-là
fait que je donne un exemple Denis
Villeneuve aux Oscars qui se fait
présenter comme un réalisateur de films
canadiens mais non non
on tombe dans le crunch de pourquoi le
Canada nous
à nouveau je vais devoir choisir Nîmes
on va voir que le Canada a vraiment un
apport limité on nous parle toujours de
diversité au Canada
mais vous remarquerez quand il est
question de la réelle diversité
linguistique et culturelle qu'est le
Québec dans le monde ça par contre ça
n'existe pas puis c'est parce que on est
dans de l'impérialisme culturel ça c'est
pas moi qui dit c'est Madame Tate qui
est à la tête de la CBC qui dit il y a
un impérialisme culturel anglais
américain donc on nous parle de
diversité mais en fait c'est de la
standardisation de la pensée culturelle
par un empire qui existe depuis quand
même des siècles et donc il y a jamais
d'espace pour la diversité québécoise
pourtant c'est un mot qui utilisait le
constamment dans le régime canadien
d'où la nécessité de l'indépendance du
Québec
parce qu'au-delà de ça comme tu disais
les exemples se multiplient de tu vois
Alexandre Bilodeau gagner une médaille
aux Jeux olympiques en ce qui
acrobatique puis tu es rempli de fierté
sauf que il monte sur le podium avec le
drapeau canadien puis il y a des gens du
Canada du Comité olympique qui s'assure
de contrôler les drapeaux québécois ça a
toujours été là
c'est vraiment le c'est la même chose
que tu as pas le droit de parler
français dans le vestiaire d'Équipe
Canada c'est de la suppression
qui me parle de diversité
non non mais c'est pour ça je vous dis
c'est quand on regarde comme il faut ce
qui se passe il y a pas d'avenir
lumineux pour le Québec dans cet
ensemble là puis il faut être capable
d'apprécier l'ensemble de notre histoire
aussi pour voir qu'il y a des constantes
quand quelque chose est constant les
chances c'est comme étant couple avec
quelqu'un qui dit je vois changer le mec
ça fait 6 ans que ça change pas il y a
un moment donné il faut en tirer une
conclusion mais c'est là que les
Québécois on leur plus gros défi
la CAC au fond invite de sortir d'une
relation toxique mais ça prend un peu de
Gap ça prend un peu de gosse puis
il y a toujours une invitation à ce
compter des histoires c'est ce que la
Capelle elle nous amène toujours avec
des déclarations qui nous fait penser
qu'au fond ça va ça va être correct ça
va ça va changer
le plus gros défi des Québécois c'est ça
c'est est-ce que
tu veux que l'histoire finisse bien ou
tu veux qu'elle finisse mal puis si tu
veux qu'elle finisse bien
es-tu prête
à être debout puis à poser des gestes
qui demandent un certain courage à mes
yeux un courage relatif c'est comme
quand on me disait le serment roi c'est
impossible tu y arriveras jamais
finalement ça a pris 12 minutes puis le
lendemain matin tout le monde dit oh
c'était évident fallait le faire c'était
sûr mais je vous le dis le
l'indépendance du Québec ce qui va
arriver c'est que la lendemain matin on
va se lever on va tous avoir la
conscience d'avoir vécu un moment
historique
mais il y a personne après qui va
enlever la main pour dire et moi je veux
continuer à demander des tweets puis je
vais écrire des lettres qui commander
ajuster un Trudeau il y a plus personne
qui va dire ça puis tout le monde va
s'empresser justement de quel délégation
à l'ONU puis comment est-ce qu'on bâtit
notre personne va vouloir revenir en
arrière donc moi je pense c'est moins
gros qu'on peut le penser mais parce que
le Canada utilise beaucoup la peur en
tout cas dans les deux référendum
c'était la peur contre les Écossais
c'est la peur contre les Catalans c'est
la peur sachant que c'est la peur qui
sera l'argument qu'on utilise est-ce
qu'on a la force de caractère
de se donner raison puis de donner un
dénouement heureux à la longue histoire
depuis les patriotes ce qu'on est
capable de ça c'est ça la question de
fond
ça sonne vraiment comme
tu es dans une relation de merde plus tu
dis c'est même trop gros finir ça c'est
pas trop gros ça a été
deux enfants
après que ça se soit réglé ça va être
mieux puis après que ça se soit réglé là
ça va être que après que ça finit jamais
puis là quand tu termines la relation le
lendemain matin tu te réveilles puis on
dirait que tu as enlevé une carapace
de syndrome de Stockholm là dedans
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a un qui est
méprisant envers l'autre
et cet autre là il y a une partie
intérieure et cela vous pas mais il y a
une partie intérieure qui aimerait ça
plaire et être à la hauteur de la
personne qui fait du bowling qui se dit
bah je suis quand même peut-être mieux
avec que tu le dis mais je vais montrer
que j'étais à la hauteur de me faire
mépriser
puis tu essayes puis tu essayes tu
essayes puis le bashing continue le
bashing continue puis il y a des gens
parce que là évidemment une société
c'est pas une personne donc ça se divise
en plein individu il y a des gens qui
devant ça vont se dire ben moi je vais
me mettre du côté de duboulis
ça va assurer mon succès
rappelons que plusieurs des entreprises
qu'on a Montréal leur siège social est à
Toronto rappelons que le système
judiciaire le système médiatique de
Radio-Canada tout ça est relié à la
fédération canadienne donc il y en a qui
devant cette relation toxique vont
vouloir juste s'en détacher puis de se
placer du côté où est-ce que tu fais pas
cogner sur la tête alors que moi j'ai
choisi vraiment le forfait chaudron là
c'est à dire je suis dans la position
par excellence ou est-ce que je dois
manger des coups de chaudron sur la tête
puis tout ça va demeurer tant qu'on
n'aura pas fait un choix cohérent mais
la cohérence demande du courage c'est
vrai individuellement pour toutes sortes
de situations dans notre vie
choisir également la vérité sur le
mensonge être capable de reconnaître
qu'on se met en nous-mêmes qu'on accepte
passivement des mensonges parce que le
mensonge ne peut pas être garant d'un
avenir radieux
c'est il faut vivre dans la vérité si on
veut bâtir des choses solides mais ça à
nouveau ça demande du courage la
facilité
c'est de d'accepter le mensonge puis
ensuite de se détacher sur des choses
qu'on contrôle ça donne une petite bulle
à nous là chez les boomers ça va être le
prochain voyage c'est son à la retraite
pour des jeunes coupes ça va peut-être
être la rénovation de la salle de bain
puis du salon pour outiler les enfants
dans le sport on va se réfugier dans des
bulles plus privées
parce que on s'imagine qu'on n'est pas
capable de vivre dans la vérité puis de
prendre des décisions conséquentes avec
les faits avec la réalité
c'est ça mon rôle c'est de sur mon
compte twitter c'est marqué entrepreneur
en pays il faut que je bâtisse
cette volonté de se défaire de la
toxicité puis de se défaire du mensonge
qui est pas propre au Canada passant et
propre a pas mal tous les régimes
d'origine coloniale on étudie à peu près
toutes les mêmes patates dans les pays
qui ont été dans le colonialisme
c'est-à-dire une partie des élites qui
véhiculent le mensonge en échange de
position avantageuse
puis une forme
de répression de toute remise en
question mais pas trop violente pour pas
non plus créer de véritables révoltes
donc très récurrentes
heureuse ou mauvaises outils mais pour
ça faut d'abord avant tout que les
Québécois soit fier
qu'il aime leur langue qu'il aime leur
culture pour pour que eux
une fin d'histoire où est-ce qu'on la
protège ou est-ce que on est indépendant
où est-ce que
où est-ce que c'est
pour que pour cette personne là pour que
ça soit une fin heureuse faut l'aimer
c'est justement tu parlais de suspects
même la question de la langue et pas
nécessairement une évidence pour pour
des amis et puis quelqu'un qui disait
mais la langue change puis si la langue
évolue puis si on parle plus anglais bah
tu es l'importance et qu'on se comprenne
les uns les autres c'est
que ça soit en français ou en anglais ou
en peu importe
ce que ça veut dire
moi j'accorde l'importance à ce que mon
père puis ma mère m'ont transmis à ce
que mon grand-père réalisé mon
grand-père mon grand-angle sont les
co-fondateurs du Carnaval de Québec et
puis il y avait un auberge puis je
m'intéresse à au cheminement des
Québécois parce que je pense que ça
définit qui je suis aujourd'hui
tu imagines que cette phrase là de ton
ami c'est un peu de renoncer à soi-même
c'est de dire au fond je pourrais être
n'importe qui
j'ai tellement pas de valeur
sur le plan culturel et linguistique et
historique que si on me demandait d'être
quelqu'un d'autre
puis de parler une langue que je
maîtrise partiellement mais qui
éventuellement je pourrais m'assurer que
mes enfants
si on me demande un déracinement complet
je vais le prendre plutôt que de
m'assumer puis d'exister puis décider
par moi-même et faut pas le prendre à la
légère parce que c'est ce que les gens
Nouvelle-Orléans ont fait si on vend à
Louisiane dans les cimetières de la
Nouvelle-Orléans les noms de famille
dans les cimetières c'est des Thibault
c'est tout et ils n'ont pas été forcés
d'apprendre l'anglais c'est qu'il y a un
moment donné il y a une génération qui a
dit moi je vois éduquer mes enfants
entièrement en anglais pour qu'il soit
pas handicapé comme moi parce quand tu
es dans un gros ensemble qui fonctionne
dans une langue puis que ton
sous-ensemble est minoritaire il y a un
moment donné tu as l'impression de vivre
avec un handicap
c'est un peu bêta qu'on devait HS ou
My Space compte facebook il y a mon ami
qui pue du bon côté
c'est pour ça que c'est très rare que
des langues et survécues à un État
national où ils sont minoritaires puis
tu peux survivre le moi j'ai vécu
Danemark je parle Danois sont pas là
elles sont pas nombreux puis c'est pas
drôle Danemark mais c'est un état c'est
un pays donc lors danois va demeurer
mais si le Danois les Danois avait été
conquis par l'Allemagne qui était
demeuré dans le système allemand pendant
plusieurs siècles les changes que danois
ne se fasse pas marginaliser son mince
donc c'est là que quand je vous dis que
l'indépendance est une nécessité
c'est que on va en venir à se dire qu'au
fond c'est pas si pire de ne pas exister
parce que on va se dire dans l'ensemble
canadien et nord-américain là parce que
c'est vraiment un système culturel et
linguistique
de toute façon on n'est pas capable de
d'exister donc aussi bien faire une
croix
mais falloir dos disait c'est mourir
culturellement puis linguistiquement
c'est long ça fait mal ça dure longtemps
c'est pas du jour au lendemain c'est un
long déclin qui vient avec encore plus
de mépris moins considération regardez
le traitement des canadiens francophones
dans les autres provinces
je peux pas croire que c'est ce qu'on va
choisir et que c'est ce qu'on donne aux
prochaines générations
je peux pas croire qu'on va faire ça
c'est pas simple c'est pas simple
psychologiquement c'est pas simple
pour ce qu'on souhaite pour l'humanité
c'est pas soin sain sur le plan de la
diversité linguistique et culturelle la
planète puis je suis sûr que si on est
un pays
quand on va l'être on va faire une
différence étonnante à l'échelle
internationale sur les questions qu'on a
nommé l'environnemental promotion de la
paix un esprit un peu patenteux Joe bon
temps c'est il y a pas d'élite très
prestigieuse au Québec tout le monde est
accessible donc en diplomatie ça veut
dire qu'on a un approche
différente je suis sûr que si on regarde
les avantages
puisqu'on réaliserait une fois
indépendant il y a pas de raison de se
dire je prête à disparaître moi-même je
le vois pas
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour avoir un
passeport québécois ah je l'ai j'en ai
plein j'ai la voiture de remplacement
je vais aller voir c'est sûr que vous
avez vos passeports québécois dedans
dedans il y a un mot que j'ai rédigé sur
la conception de la citoyenneté
québécoise le rappelle que le fait de
faire naître un pays va renforcer notre
sentiment à tous et chacun d'être
pleinement québécois renforcer les liens
peu importe les différences qu'on peut
avoir puis ensuite c'est des citations
de poètes de politiciens qui ont marqué
notre histoire et qui ont voulu à
différentes époques qu'on devienne un
pays pour nous faire réaliser puis être
comme des photos où on a vraiment fait
comme un passeport là avec des photos en
fond de des photos marquantes du Québec
mais on l'a vraiment fait dans la
perspective c'est pas mon idée en
passant ça a été faite par un évêque
dans les années 70
on le fait dans la perspective de
rappeler à quel point cette idée là est
profondément ancrée dans chacune des
générations de québécoise de Québécois
depuis avant les patriotes mais ça c'est
évidemment le plus matérialisé à partir
des patriotes mais ça fait très
longtemps que l'idée est là comme si
notre passé nous parlait puis nous
disait il y a un destin il y a quelque
chose un cycle qui est pas terminé
pourtant c'est constant c'est pas un
hasard d'une période là tout le temps là
donc il y a un
livre où il y a plusieurs chapitres et
ça va prendre un chapitre de conclusion
puis là vraiment la question ta
discussion avec les amis elle est
fascinante parce que faut choisir quelle
conclusion dans le livre
en Louisiane puis dans certaines
provinces canadiennes la conclusion
c'est
la fin de cette aventure linguistique et
culturelle
et dans ce qu'on propose c'est la
naissance
d'un pays
il est encore à rédiger c'est sûr qu'il
va y avoir un chapitre de conclusion à
ce livre-là donc on a fait le passeport
pour réaliser le faire réaliser tout ce
que les gens ont pu dire sur cette idée
là à travers les siècles
mettons sur le
besoin je repartir avec ça non mais moi
j'accompagne à tourner un artiste qui
s'appelle Ariane roi qui chante en
français qui fait de la chanson et puis
quand j'étais au secondaire si tu dis
qu'il y a eu un creux de vagues de
discuter avec Paul Piché
québécoise je m'identifiais pas vraiment
à ça puis mes amis non plus puissaient
pas je me souviens même je t'écoutais la
musique plus puis Claude rajote qui
faisait des
critiques d'album à Manille je me
souviens l'album de Vincent Vallières
parce que il y avait dit tout comme moi
j'aime pas vraiment sûr le Québécois le
musique en français mais en tout cas
j'ai revu ce que les plus récemment je
me suis sympa de bon sang de dire ça
même c'est de juste dire comme j'aime
pas ça le québécois comme si c'était
toujours été comme ça mais au cinéma
mais maintenant en tout cas je trouve
que il y a une nouvelle génération de
plus jeune que moi encore qui viennent
au chaud plus jeunes que toi
qui viennent connaître les tonnes ils
triple les artistes francophones il y a
une belle relève de
musique francophone de culture
francophone dont les gens s'intéressent
peut-être que moi je vis dans un micro
Coste une petite bulle parce que les
gens dans les militants du Parti
québécois on a un afflux inexplicable
de jeune âgés entre 15 et 22 ans puis
c'est pas nous qui avons fait quoi que
ce soit il y a comme il débarquent
ça a lieu je sais pas comment mais si il
y a des cycles il y a une forêt ça
repousse comme dans L'Homme qui plantait
des arbres
mais
non moi j'ai en fait j'ai très espoirs
parce que il y a des retours de
balancier constamment et je trouve que
ceux qui sont plus jeunes que moi je
suis quand même à 46 ans maintenant
ils ont pas mal moins peur que les
générations qui les autres générations
la peur chez mes parents jouaient
beaucoup là dans leur vote en 80 en 95
je regarde comment les questions
sociales sont abordées
peut-être c'est un sentiment d'urgence
généralisée qui fait qu'il y a moins de
peur
mais la peur de ne pas risquer le
télépès d'approche tellement prudente
que tu finis par te tirer dans le pied
je la vois pas je vois l'inverse une
espèce de volontariat
donc non je t'accepte
à tout le monde
je pense qu'on mérite et qu'on va avoir
un autre rendez-vous avec l'histoire
ce sera nous ensuite de voir qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait j'imagine que le temps
file puis que on doit tirer à notre faim
mais comment
qu'on rassemble les indépendantistes
c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas le seul
parti c'est le PQ pour le seul parti
indépendantiste
promouvoir l'indépendance avec sur
d'autres plans de différence quand même
fondamental qui fait que c'est difficile
de voir une coalition indépendante qui
regrouperait tous ces parties là comment
je pense moi j'ai l'impression que si on
veut y arriver faut qu'il y a une
certaine forme de cohésion de cohésion
Bitcoin
c'est difficile on en a pas besoin sur
le plan électoral première chose
tu peux avoir des parties différentes en
fait si le système était réformé moi je
pense pas vraiment réformer le système
de scrutin d'avoir des parties qui
représentent des idées puis des réalités
différentes en fait c'est très positif
donc des fois il y a dans le
commentarium médiatique le volonté de
mettre en bois tout le monde c'est pas
une bonne idée c'est très très sain
d'avoir des perspectives différentes je
pense que c'est faux quand même
déclenche faut que tu déclenches un
référendum pour que la question se pose
puis à ce moment-là faut que ceux qui
pensent que Louis doit gagner travail
sans se nuire et c'est pas simple ça non
plus
parce que la perspective de Québec
solidaire ils l'ont dit souvent c'est on
veut un pays mais pas n'importe lequel
suivant nos conditions quand je vous dis
que la table de promotion de socialisme
marxiste les ministres plus de place que
le drapeau du Québec il y a eu plusieurs
déclarations de QS qui sous un qui
peuvent laisser qu'on entendre que si le
projet d'indépendance est pas défini
comme eux le définirait
mais leur engagement serait incertain
donc ma perspective celle du pqlatus
c'est que on n'est pas une société très
différente des autres sociétés
occidentales il y a des gens qui pensent
à droite il y a des gens qui pensent à
gauche mais au final si on peut juste
s'entendre sur le fait qu'on décide par
nous-mêmes au lieu de laisser Ottawa
décider s'entendre sur le fait d'exister
à l'international c'est déjà une
réalisation colossale faisons un pays
puis ensuite
ça devient très à gauche OK puis s'il y
a des réformes à droite ok mais tant que
c'est la volonté du monde moi je crois
la démocratie d'abord et avant tout
donc c'est pas donné
sauf que c'est pas que des problèmes
parce que
dans l'éventualité au Québec solidaire
accepte que il y a pas juste sa vision
de la société puis que si on veut 50%
plus un et créer un pays il faut avoir
du respect pour toutes les opinions des
gens qu'on peut potentiellement
rassembler si on obtient ça de QS mais
c'est pas une mauvaise chose d'avoir des
véhicules qui se ressemblent pas mais
qui parle de la même idée pourquoi parce
que ça donne des interlocuteurs
différents donc c'est pas tout négatif
mais il y a une pression médiatique qui
est absolument
déconnectée de la réalité politique là
tu as pas intérêt à prendre des parties
qui s'entendent pas puis à dire faisant
un seul véhicule
c'est vraiment un plan pour pour arriver
à rien de bon puis là en cas de
référendum en cas de consultation
populaire
mais là on va voir le vrai visage de
chaque formation de chaque politique
dans la volonté réelle ou non de
promouvoir juste l'essentiel puis de
faire confiance au québécoise au
Québécois par après sur leur jugement
parce que je pense à nous distingue on
est quand même une société plus
équitable que Ben ailleurs dans le monde
c'est un peu dans notre façon de voir la
vie donc je suis très confiant au
jugement du monde sur ces questions là
d'orientation gauche droite là
est-ce que tu crois juste en finissant
est-ce que tu crois que si jamais
on redéclenchait un référendum est-ce
que tu crois que beaucoup de monde qui
sortiraient du placard dans d'autres
formations politiques
finalement c'est la théorie de Parisot
Parisot avec tout le bagage qu'il avait
se faisait ridiculiser parce qu'il
semblait tellement empressé d'amener la
question de l'indépendance tout le monde
au début lui disait ça a été difficile
là au début il y avait pas beaucoup de
soutien
mais lui sa théorie c'était de dire si
tu forces la question les gens vont
répondre mais si sont dans un
environnement où on leur dit que ça
arrivera jamais vu que c'est impossible
mais évidemment qu'avec toutes les
facteurs dont je vous parlais tantôt
c'est à dire des entreprises qui ont
leur siège social à Toronto un
environnement médiatique qui souvent
nous répète que c'est pas une bonne idée
mais évidemment que les gens sont gris
effacer même vont juste pas y toucher
pour être certain de pas avoir de
troubles mais si tu places la question
pour de vrai dans un contexte où il y a
plein de bons arguments puis que tout le
monde doit répondre une réponse binaire
mais oui surtout que le fédéral après le
référendum de 95 s'est mis à investir en
culture puis dans les universités qui
sont nos champs de compétences mais
ramassent plus d'impôts que ce qu'il y
en a besoin fait qu'est-ce qu'ils font
il interviennent dans des endroits où
typiquement il y avait vraiment une
pensée indépendante en disant mais si tu
veux du financement oui mais va falloir
que tu répondes à mes critères puis
l'homme est à toute l'idéologie
canadienne dont le but est notamment
d'empêcher l'indépendance du Québec donc
si on a un rendez-vous historique je
pense les gens vont se libérer de cette
influence financière pour dire bah là
pour une fois dans ma vie il y a un
moment d'histoire puis je l'assume puis
je sors publiquement alors qu'au
quotidien probablement que j'aurais fait
faillite ou en tout cas que j'aurais eu
des problèmes financiers plus importants
en me coupant de toute
le financement fédéral donc faut forcer
la question si on veut un moment de
vérité
puis on peut si on veut permettre à des
gens qui n'en pensent pas moins de tout
d'un coup jouer leur rôle au bon moment
merci beaucoup merci